رسمت الدراسات السابقه صوره اكثر قتامه
للكثافه السكانيه في العام الماضي مثلا
قدرت الامم المتحده ان عدد سكان العالم
سيصل الى 9 مليارات و700 مليون نسمه بحلول
منتصف القرن وسيستمر في الارتفاع لعده
عقود بعد ذلك لكن بحسب الدراسه الجديده
فانه في حاله العمل كالمعتاد يتوقع ان
تكون السياسات الحاليه كافيه للحد من
النمو السكاني العالمي الى اقل من تسعه
مليارات في عام 2046 ثم تنخفض الى سبعه
مليارات و300 مليون في عام 2100 في
السيناريو الثاني الاكثر تفائلا ومع قيام
الحكومات في جميع انحاء العالم برفع
الضرائب على الاثرياء للاستثمار في
التعليم والخدمات الاجتماعيه وتحسين
المساواه يقدر ان الاعداد البشريه يمكن ان
تصل الى ثمانيه مليارات ونصف المليار في
وقت مبكر من عام 2040 ثم بنحو عام واحد
الى حوالي سته مليارات في 2100 وفقا لهذه
الدراسه فانه بحلول عام 2050 تكون
انبعاثات غاز الاحتباس الحراري اقل بنسبه
90% تقريبا مما كانت عليه في عام 2020
وذلك بعد انخفاض اعداد السكان لكن
المؤلفين لهذه الدراسه يحضرون من ان يؤدي
انخفاض عدد السكان ايضا الى خلق مشاكل
جديده مثل تقليص القوى العامله زياده
الضغط على الرعايه الصحيه المرتبطه
بمجتمعات الشيخوخه كاليابان مثلا وكوريا
[موسيقى]